por primera vez en 5 años el presidente
nicolás maduro entregó su informe de
gobierno ante la asamblea nacional el
mandatario venezolano defendió su
gestión de la pandemia del cómic 19
debemos actuar en conjunto he pedido a
la comisión presidencial y pido a esta
asamblea que nos apoye nos ayude tomaron
conjunta acciones orientadas al
perfeccionamiento del modelo 77 a la
ampliación de los tratamientos para la
cura de los nuevos contagiados de manera
universal como debe ser maduro agregó
que unas 10 millones de dosis de la
vacuna rusa estarían por llegar a
venezuela en los próximos días en su
mensaje a la nación maduro aseguró que
2021 sería el año de la recuperación de
venezuela de cuya crisis responsabilizó
en las sanciones de eeuu y la unión
europea pasamos de tener más de 50 mil
millones de dólares en 2013 a disponer
apenas de 743 millones en el año 2020
quiere decir de cada 100 dólares o euros
que el país obtenía por la venta de
petróleo en 2014 hoy o tiene un poco más
de un dólar por su parte el líder
opositor venezolano juan guaidó quien es
reconocido por más de 60 países como el
presidente legítimo de venezuela
arremetió en twitter en contra de maduro
ante las mentiras del dictador en la
imagen un resumen por lo que debe rendir
cuentas a la justicia delitos de lesa
humanidad terrorismo y narcotráfico con
recompensa de 15 millones de dólares
mientras que la asamblea nacional estuvo
bajo el control de la oposición entre
2016 y 2020
el presidente venezolano nicolás maduro
solamente acudió al parlamento en una
ocasión 2016 y allí debió afrontar los
cuestionamientos del entonces presidente
del legislativo el opositor henry ramos
ayuda